Today in history, on October 10th, 732
AD, a brutal battle was waged to decide
whether Europe remained Christian or
whether it would become Muslim.
Exactly 100 years earlier in 632,
Islam's prophet Muhammad died. In the
intervening century, his followers swept
across and conquered the greater part of
Christendom from Syria and Egypt to
North Africa and Spain. By 732, 1
century after Muhammad's death, the
scimitar of Islam had reached the very
heart of Europe, confronting its
greatest military power at the time, the
Franks.
In 731, the ruthless governor of
Al-Andalus conquered Spain, Abdal-Rahman
al-Ghafiqi, described in sources as a
quote warlike man, led 80,000 Muslim
raiders into Francia, France, where they
devastated the countrysides. In the
words of an Arabian chronicler, quote
the men of Abdal-Rahman were puffed up
in spirit by their repeated successes
against the Christians. And they were
full of trust in the valor and the
practice in war of their emir,
Abdal-Rahman. So the Muslims smote their
enemies and laid waste the country and
took captives without number. And that
army went through all places like a
desolating storm. Everything gave way to
their scimitars, which were the robbers
of lives. All the nations of the Franks
trembled at that terrible army, and they
betook themselves to their king,
Charles, and told him of the havoc made
by the Muslim horsemen and how they rode
at their will through all the lands. The
destruction was profound. In the words
of Edward Gibbon, quote the memory of
these devastations, for Abdal-Rahman did
not spare the country or the people, was
long preserved by tradition. The richest
spoil was found in the churches and
monasteries which they stripped of their
ornaments before delivering to the
flames. Alas, what a misfortune, the
Franks are quoted as saying, what an
indignity. We have long heard of the
name and conquests of the Arabs. We were
apprehensive of their attack from the
east. They have now conquered Spain and
invade our country on the side of the
west. By the early 730s, Muslims
controlled nearly all the great cities
between the Pyrenees, the mountains that
separate Spain and France, and the Rhone
River, slaughtering Christians, burning
a bishop alive, and despoiling every
church and monastery in their path. The
ultimate target was Tours, where
Abdal-Rahman imagined he could pillage
the Basilica of Saint Martin. In the
words of a chronicler, but before he
reached that shrine, he found himself
face-to-face with the lord of Austrasia.
Eastern land is what it means, as in
Eastern France. Charles, a mighty
warrior from his youth, continues the
same chronicler. There and then, on
October 10th, somewhere between Poitiers
and Tours, Abdal-Rahman's 80,000 Muslim
raiders met Charles's 30,000 Christian
warriors. An anonymous medieval Arab
chronicler describes the battle that
followed in the following words. Quote
near the River Loire, the two great
hosts of the two languages, Arabic and
Latin, and the two creeds, Islam and
Christianity, were set in array against
each other. The hearts of Abdal-Rahman,
his captains, and his men were filled
with wrath and pride, and they were the
first to begin to fight. The Muslim
horsemen dashed fierce and frequent
forward against the battalions of the
Franks, who resisted manfully, and many
fell dead on either side until the going
down of the sun. Entirely consisting of
wild, headlong charges, the Muslim
attack proved ineffective. For quote the
men of the north stood as motionless as
a wall. They were like a belt of ice
frozen together and not to be dissolved
as they slew the Arab with the sword.
The Austrasians, Eastern Franks, vast of
limb and iron of hand, hewed on bravely
in the thick of the fight, continues the
chronicler. The Franks refused to break
ranks and allow successive horsemen to
gallop through the gaps which Arab
cavalry tactics relied on. Instead, they
tightened their ranks and quote drawn up
in a band around their chief, Charles,
the people of the Franks carried all
before them. Their tireless hands drove
their swords down to the breasts of the
foe. As expected, the battle was a
wondrous mess. At one point, Allah's
warriors surrounded and trapped Charles,
but quote he fought as fiercely as the
hungry wolf falls upon the stag. By the
grace of our lord, he wrought a great
slaughter upon the enemies of Christian
faith, writes Dennis the chronicler. It
was then that he was first called
Martel, he continues, for as a hammer of
iron, of steel, and of every other
metal, even so he dashed and smote in
battle all his enemies. As night
descended on the field of carnage, the
two bloodied armies disengaged and
withdrew to their camps. At the crack of
dawn, the Franks prepared to resume
battle only to discover that the Muslims
had all fled under the cover of
darkness. Their master, Abdal-Rahman,
had been killed in fighting the day
before, and the Muslims, many of whom
were recently converted Berbers, freed
of his whip and having long tasted
Frankish metal, apparently preferred
life and some plunder over martyrdom.
They all fled back south, still looting,
burning, and enslaving all and sundry as
they went. Aware that his strength lay
in his wall of ice, Charles did not give
chase. The aftermath is described as a
gory mess with thousands of wounded or
dying horses strewn across the field and
abandoned plunder and dead and wounded
Arabs everywhere. Few of the wounded
were taken prisoner, not least due to
their previous record of murder and
pillage throughout France and Spain. The
oldest sources give astronomical numbers
of slain Muslims with only a small
fraction of slain Franks. Whatever the
true numbers, significantly fewer
Christians than Muslims fell on that
day. Even Arab chroniclers refer to the
engagement as the pavement of martyrs,
suggesting that the earth was littered
with Muslim corpses.
At any rate, the joyful tidings were
soon diffused all throughout Europe, and
the surviving chronicles of the day,
including that of the aforesaid
anonymous Arab, portray this victory in
epic, if not apocalyptic, terms. Indeed,
of all the many battles between Islam
and Christendom, Tours has, beginning
with the contemporary chronicles up
until the modern era, been one of, if
not the most celebrated in the west. For
although the Mediterranean was lost and
although raids on the European coastline
became a permanent feature, Islam was
confined to the Iberian Peninsula,
leaving Western Europe to develop
organically, by and large. It is for
this reason that well into the 20th
century, leading Western historians,
such as Godefroid Kurth, who died in
1916, still saw Tours as quote one of
the great events in the history of the
world, as upon its issue depended
whether Christian civilization should
continue or Islam prevail throughout
Europe.
That, of course, was then. This is now.
Islam has prevailed throughout Europe,
and not through force, but through
treachery.
[Music]